Most of the time when you hear people talk about
big data, they’re talking about it within the
commercial setting about how businesses can use
big data in advertising or marketing strategies.
But, one really important place that
big data is also used is for consumers.
What’s funny about this is that, while
the data is there and the algorithms are
there, and a incredibly sophisticated processing
is there, it’s nearly invisible. The results are
so clean. They give you just a little piece of
information, but exactly what you need. What I
want to do is show you some common applications
of big data for consumers that you may be using
already without being aware of the sophistication
of the big data analysis that’s going into it.
The first one is, if you have an Apple iPhone
or iPad, is what Siri can do. For instance,
aside from saying what’s the weather like,
and Siri actually knows what it is you mean,
and where you are, and what time you’re talking
about, it can do things like look for restaurants
of a particular kind of food and see if they have
reservations available. It can do an enormous
amount of things that requires the recommendation
of other people, awareness of your locations,
awareness of the changes over time of
what is most preferable for people.
The next one, you might be familiar
with recommendation engines.
This is an idea of software that is able to make
a specific suggestion to you. Here’s a Spotify
account, and Spotify knows what you listen to
when you’re on Spotify, and what you listen
to all the way through, what you add to your
playlist, what you skip through, and it’s able
to make specific suggestions to help you find new
artists that you wouldn’t otherwise know about.
Similarly, Amazon.com makes
recommendations for books.
For instance, here’s a book, Principles
of Big Data, by Jules Berman,
and if you scroll down you’ll see that they
have a list of other books that are recommended.
This is generated by Amazon’s recommendation
engine, and you see several other books on big
data, and in fact, it’s a great list.
It’s the same general principle here.
A lot of people use Netflix to get movies.
Netflix makes specific suggestions
for other movies you might like.
What’s interesting is that a few years ago they
had a major contest called the Netflix Prize where
they wanted to see if anybody could improve the
accuracy of their predictions, meaning would you
actually like this. If they could improve those
predictions by 10%, it was a million dollar prize
and it was incredibly sophisticated analysis that
went into this, but the end result again is a very
simple thing, you get recommended a hand full of
movies, and usually you pick one and you like it.
So for consumers, big data plays an enormous
role in providing valuable services, but again,
with the irony that it operates invisibly by
taking a huge amount of information from several
different sources and distilling it into just
two or three things that give you what you need.
We saw that big data can provide important
conveniences and functionality for consumers,
but for the business world, big data is
revolutionizing the way people do commerce.
We will look at a few particular places where
big data has proven to be particularly useful,
or unusual and interesting. The first thing
we’re going to do is look at the place where
most people have encountered big data in commerce,
and that’s in the results for Google ad searches.
Whenever you search for something on Google or
any other search engine, you type in your term.
You’re going to get the results that you
want, but you’re also going to get ads.
You see here, for instance, on the top
when you’re searching for big data.
There are three ads on the top, and there
is a series of ads down the right side.
Those ads are not placed at random. They’re
placed there because they are based first on
the thing that you’re currently searching for,
but also based on what Google knows about you.
You can see in the top right that someone has
logged in to his account, so Google is drawing
on all of the things that he has searched for, and
the other information it has about him, to try to
place ads that it thinks he would be most likely
to respond to. That’s something it gets by having
a very large amount of data available, to tailor
things to be most applicable to the consumer.
Another interesting place is what’s called
predictive marketing. This is when big data
is used to help decide who the audience would
be for something before they actually get there.
This is trying to predict, for
example, major life events,
like for instance graduating, or getting
married, or getting a new job, or having a child,
or any number of events that are often associated
with a whole series of commercial transactions.
To do this, these companies can look at
consumer behavior. They can look at how
often you log onto their website. They can
look at what credit cards you use. They can
look at how often you look at particular
items before moving on to something else.
They can look at whether you’ve applied
for an account at their organization.
They can make a huge amount of information that
they already have available to them. Similarly,
they can use demographic information. This can
include things like your age, your marital status,
the number of children you have, your home
address, how far you live from their store, your
estimated salary, if you’ve moved recently, what
credit cards you have, what websites you visit.
All of this information is potentially available
in one form or another, to the company that’s
trying to make these predictions. Similarly,
they can rely on additional purchased data.
It’s possible for the company to get information
about your ethnicity, your job history,
your magazine subscriptions, whether you’ve
declared bankruptcy or been divorced,
whether you’ve attended college, the kind
of things you talk about online, and so on.
There’s an enormous amount of information here
that again is potentially available. Using this
kind of information, it is possible for a company
to predict that you’re about to buy a new house,
and that when you buy a new house you
make an enormous number of purchases,
and so they can link in to you before you
start making the commitments to those.
Another place we want to talk about
big data is trying to predict trends.
One of the really fascinating places for
this is in fashion. The company Editd
has actually received awards for their use
of big data in predicting fashion trends.
So they can actually tell retailers what
the most popular colors and styles and
brands are going to be, when they’re going to
be popular, and they can help them price them.
Obviously, this kind of information is enormously
important to the companies that are going to be
selling these products, and Editd is able to
do this through their reliance on big data.
Finally, one of the interesting use of big data
in commerce is for fraud detection. It turns out
that fraud is an enormous industry, that online
retailers lose about $3.5 billion each year to
online fraud, and insurance fraud, not counting
health insurance, is estimated to be more than
$40 billion per year. So fraud is a big issue.
It turns out that there’s a number of things
that companies can do to lessen the prevalence
of fraud, especially through online transactions.
They can look at the point of sale.
That specifically means, how are you
making the purchase? Are you online,
and what website are you using? They can use
geolocation. Where are you physically located
in the world? They can look at the IP address.
What computer are you using to access the website.
They can look at the log in time. Are you
somehow making a purchase at 4:00 a.m.,
when you’ve never before done anything
after 11:00 p.m. . Interestingly,
they can also look at things like biometrics. For
instance, the way that people move their mouse,
or the time they take between pressing keys on the
computer, are distinctive measurements of people.
A lot of this was made possible because of the
particular details and the patterns that they
have in their extraordinarily large data set, let
them recognize these anomalies as potential fraud.
We have looked at the role that big
data can play in individual people’s
lives as well as in businesses. We
also want to look very quickly at
how big data has been revolutionizing
aspects of scholarship and research.
There are a few interesting examples of where
big data has influenced scientific progress.
The first one we want to look at is Google flu
trends where they were able to find that search
patterns for flu related words were actually
able to identify outbreaks of the flu in the
United States much faster than the research
that the Center for Disease Control could do.
Similarly, a more recent project found that
Wikipedia searches could identify
them with even greater accuracy.
Psychological research has also been influenced
through big data. In 2013, a paper published
about personalities in the United States was
able to identify clusters of personalities,
in regions where we have the mid-western friendly
and conventional region[sPause sec=0.4 ePause],
the western relaxed and creative region[sPause
sec=0.4 ePause], and a northeastern and somewhat
southern temperamental and uninhibited
region[sPause sec=0.4 ePause]. This is
not based on simply how do you feel about the
places, but this is published in a journal from
the American Psychological Association, a
very high quality psychological research.
Similarly, another group of researchers created an
application on Facebook that used a scientifically
valid measure of personality. They collected
data from several hundred thousand respondents.
And by combining those with the patterns of
likes, that each of those people had on Facebook,
to give a surprisingly accurate evaluation
of what your personality would be.
Finally, the Google Books project. For the last
few years, Google has been scanning books that
were published over the last few hundred years.
They currently have over 30 million books that
they have scanned, they make them digitally
accessible, and that allows people in Digital
Humanitites to look at the changes in word usage
over time. There’s some interesting things. For
instance, we have the last 208 years of the
prevalence of the word, ‘math’[sPause sec=0.4
ePause], ‘arithmetic’[sPause sec=0.4 ePause],
and ‘algebra’. The term ‘arithmetic’ shows a
strong spike in the 20s and 30s, but it decreases
over time [sPause sec=0.4 ePause],whereas the
word ‘math’ has increased over the last 50 to
60 years, with a peak right around year 2000.